cet engagement n'est pas offensif il est
défensif
l'alliance ne me lave pas la russie
l'europe ne menace pas la russie
personne ne menace la russie en revanche
il nous appartient de montrer à la
russie que notre unité est sans faille
quand il s'agit de défendre nos alliés
personne ne menace la russie vient-elle
de déclaré bruno daroux on sait que les
troupes françaises sont sur place des
forces de réaction rapide c'est une
première c'est de la pure dissuasion ou
est-ce qu'on pourrait être amené à
intervenir oui alors il ya il ya des
canaux ce que vous avez dit aussi les
chasseurs alpins qui sont sont sur place
500 français au total qui ont été
déployés en roumanie et évidemment ce
faisant la france 2 qu'on vient
d'entendre la ministre française désarmé
s'inscrit dans le renforcement en fait
globale de la frontière orientale de
l'otan à peut-être le voir sur la carte
des pays baltes à la pologne hongrie
roumanie justement et bien l'otan
renforce ses positions le long de toute
cette ligne là tout simplement parce que
il estime qu' effectivement personne ne
menace la russie mais la russie elle
menace alors le cren elle fait plus
calme que la menace est elle la grèce
mais potentiellement elle pourrait
menacer l eppei de l'otan donc le
message envoyé à vladimir poutine c'est
un message d'unité de fermeté et de
renforcement des effectifs pour lui dire
en gros bas au cas où tu y penserait n'y
pense plus parce que nous nous sommes
prêts à riposter alors il faut dire
qu'il ya eu des déclarations de vladimir
poutine qui peuvent être préoccupantes
même si c'est certainement de la
rhétorique fait pour alimenter sa
propagande où il estime par exemple que
les sanctions économiques sont une forme
d'acte de guerre contre lui il y as on
en parlait il y à une heure le fait que
les américains s'apprêtent peut-être à
fournir des des f 16 à la pologne parce
que la pologne elle fournirait des
avions de fabrication russe à l'ukraine
lire poutine pour le coup peut estimer
qu'il s'agit là d'un cas limite de co
belligérance donc en fait les alliés de
l'otan sauf que la situation est
extrêmement tendue qu'on est sur une
ligne de crête et au kazoo il renforce
considérablement leurs frontières au cas
où il y aurait une forme d'agression de
la part des russes